deux jeunes hommes comme vous allez voir
dans un instant s'appelle wi fi satan
aves henry se lit condamnerait dieu le
djia a quitté son corps dans un grand
éclat de rire
au moins tu te rappelles queen puis les
gens sont pas forcément mais sans du ces
sondages quand ils ont peur c'est tout
ce qui est différent d'eux ça leur fait
peur
je devais les besoins de santé roi
puissance là où la multitude voyait le
boss d'ea à veules voyait l'art quand
c'est toi
retour du tarn c'est bien par va
awa tarder les mandé à la bête j'espère
le terrain social
si tu voyais à quel point je suis là et
que toi qui puisse me rendre heureuse
c'est ce qui compte le plus au monde
pour moi on dirait une ds puisque ça
c'est une dizaine team a troublé
jamais aucun élève s'était fait sur moi
les hommes c'est abou fama et surtout
quand ils ont autant de succès jette au
château des planches à votre seigneurie
cherche quelque chose oui la sortie vous
êtes chez vous ces gens ici je suis
acceptée telle que je suis madame la
duchesse
nous avons des intérêts communs
n'avaient pas tellement envie de le voir
retourner avec des halles qui ressent
vis connaîtront télé vivante par de
nombreux ter je pourrais jamais être en
droit
j'ai peur que tu te sois trop attaché à
will play tremblay se rajoutent ne
seraient plus les mêmes
maman grotesque il 2 c'était ce qui dit
elle mon fils tu as more dur le fruit
d'or tu va retracer la bouche et de
sorde
vite d'antan théâtre ambulant donc il
est encore temps complet
je suis l'entv
la vie n'est qu'une longue perte de ceux
qu'on aime